okay now what we're going to do is we'll
use that now that we've devised what we
fixed it we'll use that to have a look
at Part C now you're asked to
differentiate you're asked to
differentiate find f dash of X so when
you're differentiating as with many
other areas in mathematics you often
have more than one path that you can
choose and part of what makes a good
mathematician is having a mastery you
knowing the different tools well enough
to know when one tool is better than
another okay I mean they'll all give you
the same result but which one's more
efficient now some of you have looked at
this first line right I'm just gonna get
rid of this blue again there we go and
you said I can differentiate that
there's a thing that I know how to
differentiate there's another thing that
I know how to differentiate but the
thing is there's an operation hiding
between those two things
that you know how to differentiate
independently there's an operation
hiding in between there that's kind of
implied what is that hiding operation
it's multiplication right which means if
you want to go with this function as
it's written you need to use the product
rule it's two things multiplied together
now you can use the product rule it's
just the real scenic route
like it'll take you a good four or five
more lines of working and every line of
working cost you time introduces places
you can make errors and all the rest so
instead of doing that instead of going
to this form and using the product rule
I'm going to go to this form and then
just treat it as a sum or a difference
of different things that I can treat
independently okay so when I do the
derivative executes can you tell the
derivative of x cubed 3x squared thank
you very much and then when you've got
that minus x squared its derivative is
minus 2x okay can I please remind you
because a lot of you are still doing
this right a lot of you this is exactly
what you've got written on the page you
said I know I'm not going to use the
first form I'm going to use this one
right you're like cool I've got it in
the form that I want BAM I'm gonna start
differentiating because you're so
focused on the calculus part of it
you've forgotten you said something
completely untrue which is the first
line is not the second line you've done
a whole thing to it it's the derivative
if I was writing in this notation and
write dy MDX okay so please just have
one extra look at your working because
it's such a natural thing to think I've
simplified now the next step but equals
does not mean next step equals means
these things are identical and if you're
going to say they're identical they
better be all right so now you've got a
derivative have we answered Part C not
quite yet Ramos they're Part C also says
hence locate any points where that guy
is zero okay so I'm gonna write that
down okay when three x squared minus 2x
equals zero and now I want to solve this
thing okay
does anyone have any suggestions for
what I could do with this that might
make it easier I don't like I don't look
at that immediately so oh there's an
answer to that right any suggestions
what I recommend I could try and turn
this fine it's a quadratic now is it
it's an x squared with some other stuff
right so if you wanted I could go like
quadratic formula on this okay but again
that kind of it kind of feels like using
a sledgehammer to open up a straight
I could factorize that'd be much more
helpful okay or I should say it much
faster to get to a helpful point so X is
the common factor right you take the X
out what's left behind 3 X minus 2
and at this point we've got the same
category of problem as we had when we're
trying to find x-intercept you member
that we were like what's the value of x
that makes that zero answer zero if you
put in x equals zero into that the whole
thing becomes zero this one takes a
little more thought what value of x do I
put into there
to make this inside the brackets make
that zero x equals two over three
why does that work right well if I go
three lots of that you get two and then
you take away two come back to zero I
know I often mistook this for three over
two because I saw the numbers I knew I
had to arrange in some way if you're
unsure like I used to be just put it
back in and find out whether it gives
you zero or not okay so these two values
will make the derivative zero have I
answered the question
I'm pretty close I'm pretty close read
the wording again very carefully it says
find f dash X done locate any locating
what points this is not a point this is
half of a point it's the X bit right I
also need the the Y bit okay now
thankfully when x equals zero I already
know what the y part is it's zero right
so x equals zero y equals zero I guess
we could write that as coordinates but I
do not know what happens with the other
value when x equals 2 over 3 you might
need to grab your calculator there I'm
just going to do it by hand that's gonna
become 4 over 9 times negative 1/3 that
sounds like minus 4 over twenty-seven
can someone tell me if that's why I
don't know I just kind of eyeballed it
but yeah - foreign 27 now I did it was
right um I've already gotten one
question wrong today so I'm that's why
I'm asking you guys to check me out ok
you got a calculator there confirmation
thank you okay I got a note from Ben so
there was another way by the way there
was another way that I kind of was
reasonably sure I was in the right
ballpark and it goes back to Part A what
was Part A what was that question
it was the graph right where is where is
x equals 2 over 3 where is it on my
picture it's like it's like here right
ish somewhere between 1/2 + 1 minus 4
over 27 that's like just a small
negative value does that check out like
if I'd done my arithmetic and I got
something positive at the end I like y
equals positive forever 27 I knew that's
wrong instantly I know it's wrong even
though I don't know the right answer is
I know to try again maybe use my
calculator but it's already in the right
ballpark so I'm happy okay all right now
what are we looking at now oh no I'm not
finished yet
Part C we're done with the answer but I
just wanted to point out why I'm
interested in these two places zero
comma zero and two thirds comma negative
4 over
27 where are they on my graph why are
they important to me do you notice that
they actually are interesting things
happening on the graph at those two
spots let me mark them in he is one of
them and then he's the other one what
are those two spots they have names they
are stationary points you might have not
have heard that phrase before you might
have heard the phrase turning points
because the graph is going up then down
it turns and the graph is going down
then up it turns right so what you
actually found right
you found the spot where the graph turns
around where max was mentioning looking
for a vertex right on a parabola it's
easy to find the vertex it's just in the
middle but a cubic doesn't have a middle
in the same way you have to use calculus
to do that okay any questions on that
does that make sense you might like to
arm if you've written down these points
like I have you might like to make a
note for yourself these are the turning
points of the graph what we actually
found was stationary points we'll get
into the difference a little bit more
later on when we're not focused on some
other stuff like assessment tasks okay
now as Part C Part D could you raise
your hand for me I'm not going to put
you on the spot I just want to get a
sense of how familiar how good your
memory is could you raise your hand for
me if you could describe to someone what
a tangent is hand-up yeah half of you
okay keep your hand up if you could do
the same for a normal okay whew that's
right that's why okay so half will you
say the tangent let's quickly I will
show you I'm gonna do it on the graph
what does a tangent look like a tangent
is a straight line and it's not just any
straight line it just touches the graph
it just touches at a certain point okay
and that point usually I've specified
for you this question does exactly that
okay that's what a tangent looks like
there's a particular spot you get asked
for it goes through that point and the
gradients match that's the important
thing the gradients match that's your
tangent for the normal it's very very
similar normals also a straight line but
can someone tell me what's the
difference between them well
perfect it is at right angles to that
tangent we just true so if this is the
tangent then this would be the normal
and I encourage you
there's my right angle I'd encourage you
maybe on a picture on your graph right
now draw one of those because way better
that like although the technical
language to describe what these things
are where better is just the picture oh
yeah it's that line that just touches I
can see it and it's the line that's at
right angles to that guy okay now this
is not the tangent or the normal I want
you to find I want you to find the
tangent normal for that given value of x
that's in the question which is x equals
two so have God that if you've if you're
hitting a brick wall or if you think
you've got an answer call mrs. Lee's
right over and then we'll see how if I
can get beyond that